hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled environmental monitoring
tools to measure microbiological control
in the food
industry i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
middle core sigma so let's get started
before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you'd
like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speaker timothy
steer
a technology specialist at miller core
sigma
timothy has worked at melipar sigma for
the last 14 years in a variety of roles
involving pharmaceutical and biotech qc
microbiology
for a complete biography on mr spear
please visit the biography tab at the
top
of your screen you may now begin
the presentation welcome again sir
thanks susie uh hey everybody welcome
welcome to the food and beverage week
with lab roots i appreciate you showing
up
and today we're going to talk about
environmental monitoring in the food
world
so let's get started i have a lot of
slides but the best part is
i don't read my slides i know that's the
worst in person it's even worse
on the web so we're not going to do that
so today we're going to talk about
environmental monitoring
is our disclaimer uh everybody has to
have these or excuse me this is uh this
is us being
the miliport sigma the a division of
merck kga
out of darmstadt this is our disclaimer
like i said that everybody has to have
um this is me talking not necessarily my
company so
that's that so who is milliport sigma in
the food and beverage industry
we might not be as well known even
though we've been in the food and
beverage industry for a long time
we're a large uh group of a bunch of
different companies over a long period
of time so we started off as merck out
of germany
uh then in 2010 we purchased millipore
which you probably know for membrane
filtration
we also purchased a company called haifa
out of germany that
creates the that makes prepared media
then we purchase biocontrol who does
pathogen detection
and then finally we we purchased sigma
aldridge which is a huge life science
company
um that services all kinds of different
uh life science
company so we are a group of five
different companies that have become one
which is milliport sigma and in your
world
what we do is we capture bugs we grow
them and then we detect them
and so for for the little qc
microbiology world that we're in
um we're miliport sigma and we're
biomonitoring that's who we are within
millipars
so we are looking for bugs and we're
looking for bugs that you're looking for
so we do have some history in
microbiology we have the first patent
in media first culture media patent we
also have
um the first ready-to-use all-in-one
suave as well as room temp media
and the first membrane in addition to
the first
pathogen detection system that uses
immunomagnetic separation
so we have a lot of firsts and we've got
a long history in microbiology
uh and this slide it just shows you all
of the different options that we have
from your sample prep all the way into
your pathogen detection
all along the way and i'm not going to
go every type of product just wanted you
to see
the breadth of products that we do offer
for any of these applications whether it
be from the start with yours
with your 25 gram sample all the way
till detecting e coli or salmonella
and the final step so what are we going
to talk about today
we're going to talk about some
regulations um em sampling plans
tools as well as all of those uh
different parts
of getting the answers that you need to
make sure that your process
is i wouldn't say clean but to make sure
that your process
is under control so
regulations well in the eu they really
do follow
um their own eu regulations and here we
have two
really usda and fda um and then we kind
of all use methods from iso there's
other kinds of methods
like from micro valves so we use
different types of methods
uh but here in the us we really follow
usda with their mlg
and the fda with the bam the
bacteriological analytical methods and
the mlg is the microbial
laboratory guidebook and so the
regulations tell us exactly what we have
to do but then each method might be a
little bit different depending on your
situation
um so we we sort of we sort of follow
iso a little bit but that's really a
european thing
more than more than anything
so what governs our environmental
monitoring what governs our production
process it's
it's hasa hazard analysis critical
control point
uh and it's just a risk-based approach
so when i look at my process
and i look to see at a point where my in
my production
where my product is touching a conveyor
that's certainly going to be a critical
control point or where a lot of people
are touching it
an on off button or a lot of people are
working in an area with a
with some with some bins those are going
to be some
some critical control points that need
to be measured
and so the usda and fda also talk about
hassab you're really just looking for
your main
control your main risks and looking to
make sure that when you do
clean those areas that they are clean
and in the process you're also measuring
the environment so you're doing this on
a risk-based uh
approach so hassep is not new and hasn't
been around for a while and what you
really do is you're just
looking at your production environment
from a microbiology standpoint
so where are the most risky parts of my
process
and that's where you want to start and
that's most likely going to be
your product control or excuse me your
product contact services
so you look at your production and you
say oh i see
here are my most critical points and
then my second group of critical points
and my third group of critical points
so you just continue down that road and
then you say
how much can i accept at that critical
point maybe it's
no pathogens whatsoever maybe it's under
100 cfu per
per gram or 100 to see a few per sample
um
per swab so you want to establish those
limits and then your procedures are you
going to use a swab are you going to use
a sponge
um uh you know what type of products
would you need to make sure that you get
that done
in a in a efficient manner and then what
happens after that
is if i find something that i'm i'm
looking for and i don't want to have
present in my environment now you have
to have a corrective action
how did it get there and if you cleaned
did you clean it well enough
to get rid of it so you want to make
sure that your corrective actions
are effective in um getting rid of that
particular
either pathogen or it could be just a
total bio burden
and then you just verify and that's what
a lot of this is a lot of environmental
monitoring is verifying
because we know that we clean and we
know that we use a lot of disinfectants
and sanitants
and we just use environmental monitoring
tools to make sure that those procedures
are working and clearly everything in
these
operations have to have good
record-keeping and documentation
and a lot of instruments out there will
help you with that without having to
write things down it's just all
automated
so establishing monitor proceed excuse
me establish monitoring procedures so we
just make sure over the course of time
that our process is working and so
in the process of whether or not we when
we ran our production and then we clean
and now we measure and then we just
repeat that cycle over and over and over
again
and we're looking for trends what the
most important thing about environment
environmental monitoring is trends
because i can have a one-off type of
situation and that might not be a big
deal
but if i continually see the same
problems over and over again
i might have a harborage or a niche
that's that's harboring
different types of pathogens so you want
to make sure that you
are are trending your data to see those
types of of
problems um so if you when you
when you're doing em you're just going
to make sure that
your process is under control and that
control is based off of you
it's based on what your company decides
that is
is important so if you have a specific
limit and that limit matters to your
type of product to your type of
environment
that's going to be a limit that will be
different from other places and so you
just want to make sure that you're
you're trending
you're then when you have those
interventions when you have those
problems
that you're able to to facilitate
getting rid of those problems
and that you don't have as many when
you're doing the environmental
monitoring
and that's what that's really forced to
make sure that you don't have
as many problems causing to a reduction
in production and a reduction in
in um uh product coming out of the
warehouse so sampling plans
um so they're following gmp and hassab
guidelines you're really just trying to
present
prevent cross-contamination and what
this really means is
you know you're trying to find the
balance you don't want to
create contamination by doing sampling
so you're just making sure that your
sanitation network is working and that
your environmental preventative controls
your doors your air locks your hvac
systems
that they're all working and that's how
you want to look so we're just going to
go over these really
really really fast um you know you're
going to choose where
how often what are you going to be
looking for what are the levels
so you could be doing personnel
monitoring air monitoring
indicator organism pathogens allergies
so you should be able to
to have a plan that decides what
part of each site do you are what are
you looking for each particular site
because it could all be different
uh so the zones that we're looking at
are usually uh usually four zones that's
the industry standard
and i'm not going to go over every
single word here but the zone one is
usually product contact surfaces
and zone two you think of as a bullseye
zone one is the bullseye
zone two is the area outside of the
bullseye the little extra area
zone three might be the bigger part and
zone four is really kind of like
again the locker rooms you're talking
about product storage maintenance
so those different zones obviously zone
one is going to be
the most important zone because you have
direct product contact
that's where you're gonna have the
majority of your testing between zone
one and zone two
zone three and zone four certainly will
have some testing but it's not as
critical as the product contact surface
so here's some examples of zone one
we're doing some a lot of sponging
sponge sickles um more sponging than
swabbing
so we've got an ice um uh
scoop there and we've got some conveyors
so those are just some examples
of some zone one sampling and then we've
got zone two so
that conveyor nook on the bottom left
that isn't product contact surface but
it's right there
and so if there's any splashing or
spilling and you're cleaning and you
realize that that could be a harborage
point
because it's a little nook a little
cranny where bugs like to live
you may consider sampling in that area
as well and there's some other examples
of what zone two would look like so zone
three again is that third
third area this drains that's um on the
upper right we've got a forklift
operators
uh hand uh excuse me steering wheel and
so those are areas where you say again
it's not going to be the most of my
sampling and they're going to be quite
dirty
um but when we talk about looking for
bugs through a facility
you may very well find that that bug has
traveled from a zone four to a zone one
you may very well see that it's traveled
from the raw material
into your zone one and so that's a good
way of if you see something in the zone
three and zone four
that that organism might be traveling
through your facility
um and then again some examples there's
a water fountain a keyboard
again these aren't going to be as common
but it certainly gives you clues as to
where you might find
uh where the contamination came from
so devices and techniques well we all
know about this bicycle it's very famous
and we got the whirlpack bags there's a
variety of different
products out there people have all kinds
of different
um they their personal choice they might
have a bag with a sponge sickle
that has the theme broth and it has um
sterile gloves they might have just just
the sponge sickle
there's lots of different options that
are out there uh but most people are
using sponges
in that zone one area and then there's
also the swabs
and we showed that with that um conveyor
crevice where someone was using kind of
a swab a little bit of a spongy swab to
get into those nooks and crevices
and so here in the swabbing pattern
you'll notice you choose the area of the
4x4
10 by 10 centimeter and you do one way
and then the other way
and that's the best swabbing pattern
that you create a nice
square and you you cover the entire
space that you're looking for
because remember this is only a snapshot
and so most a very important point is
that the sanitizers are not inhibiting
growth
a lot of times we might have sanitizers
that exist
still in our environment and we want to
make sure that when we're sampling that
those sanitizers aren't coming along for
the ride
and inhibiting growth i might have a bug
that's a little
that's able to survive it's maybe on a
biofilm it's able to survive some of
these really
um these really toxic sanitants against
toxic to the organisms
um and and we might have bugs that are
trying to survive and that sanitize
might inhibit that growth
in our process so you want to look to
make sure that some of your
some of your sampling process like
having lathine broth
or using your atp swab that has some
sort of neutralizer
that will allow those sanitants to be
neutralized and the bug can grow
if it's present um
so in the sanitizer and the neutralizers
that we're talking about
a lot of people use lifting a lot of
people use de-neutralizing and i'm not
going to go over this entire
chart but you can see that uh you know
many facilities if not most use some
sort of coordinary
ammonium compound and you can use
neutralizing buffer lifting and
de-neutralizing buffer
for those excuse me broth for those uh
coronary
ammonium compounds but buffer peptide
water doesn't work with any of them as
far as neutralizing
so this just gives you a good idea of
the type of media that you can use
in order to neutralize those sanitants
so what tools are we using well we've
got atp
allergen sampling viable sampling and
viable could be in the air or personnel
and then em indicator organism detection
tool number one atp testing i'm sure
many of you familiar with this
this is a lot of swabbing and this is
looking for atp
which is it which is present in all
cells
so we're not looking particularly for
organisms i mean we are but
we are unable to tell the difference
between say a food
residue versus an organism residue so
um we're looking for total atp and what
this really tells us is
how clean did we get our environment
when our cleaning procedure when we used
our sanitin
our ammonium compound or our parasitic
acid compound
how well did we do because atp is in
every cell
and that atp reaction will create a
light
or relative light unit um
and it's got several different terms but
it's based off of bioluminescence off of
the firefly
so atp testing is really just validating
how well we clean
it won't tell you how many organisms are
there that's not the
purpose of atp testing so here's some
visual examples here on the bottom left
is a tank
and here it might be a little you know
that's where the liquid is coming
through we all know that bugs need
some sort of water to survive a specific
amount of water activity
and anywhere anytime there's liquid
there's a chance for bugs to grow so
we've got we're going to make sure that
when we clean the this tank
that we're going to swab at those most
critical points as we discussed before
and here's a hose that we might have
cleaned and we're going to swab that as
well
as well as the rinsing water
sampling of the rinsing water and the
filtration so you can actually do liquid
and surfaces so really like i said it's
just designed to make sure that you can
measure
the validation of your cleaning process
uh and here's
in beverage and dairy your same idea
you're just using that swab
to make sure that any process um has
reduced the amount of of material that
might be there whether it be bugs
or actual product uh and so you can
check the bottles in the
in the filling area as well to ensure
that those bottles are clean too
so what do we have to offer for that
particular process is the mvp icon
it's a it's a handheld portable touch
screen
you have you can load plans into it you
can do a quick test
um it runs on on the lithium ion battery
it has about four hours
so it's not unlike other
um atp systems that are out there and
that is portable
easy to use our swab is very easy to use
we do have some advantages though
what's nice is we make it really really
easy to understand if your
atp swab is passing you get a big green
pass
everyone gets that if you're close in
your and i'll show you a chart in a
second here you'll get kind of a yellow
worn
and if you fail you'll get a red and you
have a point at that time where you can
do a retest
if if you need to if there's a someone
needs to come back in and clean and you
can do a quick re-test
we have that capability as well and one
of the most uh one of the nice features
is that we have a test point
randomization
where you're not going to be biased
testing the same
order over and over and over again you
can you can randomize your test point
and that that gets rid of any bias that
you might have in the sampling plan
and so this is what i was talking about
with that pass warn and fail
um there's relative light units and we
call them zones so you could say in the
zone
and again it's not exact because atp is
not an exact science
the amount of light that that reaction
puts off is not
um it's it's not perfect about that it's
not a chemistry
technically like a uh let's call it a
titration
so we get into the pass area and then
we're close to the worn area and we
might be say okay well we need to
we need to clean here again and then
definitely if we get into the fail area
we certainly have quite a bit of atp and
we need to go ahead and reclaim that
so um it makes it so that it gives you a
nice visual clue as to when
you're when you feel good about your
facility and when things might be
getting out of control
so the zones of cleanliness is a nice
easy way
to to see how clean your facility is in
the field so it's not something you have
to to calculate
uh and this again is just we're talking
about using the photo
counting sensor how much atp down here
um and you can see it between point five
and five there's
your worn section and then after about
five
um picograms of atp you'll see that
you're in your fail
um and anything below that that's
somewhere between point five and five
you'll see that that's in your past zone
um so
the one of the misconceptions about atp
is we can measure how much bacterial or
yeast and mold contamination
and really the best systems can only get
down to about 100
cfu as far as a contamination and if you
have 100 cfu that's pretty contaminated
on the surface
so it's just unable to tell you if you
have contamination
you're really only able to see that your
cleaning was was validated
uh and so here's our sampling device
again this
this there are other swabs there are
other atp systems on the market this is
the one that we have
and so we can give you nice pictures of
how this works we have up here in the
top
is our reagent and so we do our swabbing
and we
push our plunger into the swab and it's
going to disperse the reagent
allowing to make sure that we get rid of
any um
we're not having to worry about the swab
being in the activation process
so um as the solution flows down you'll
end up
you just press it put the uh swab into
the machine and it's going to give you a
read
really really quickly we do have
neutralizing buffer to eliminate
that potential interference from those
sanitants
so this just gives you a another another
secure feature of making sure that the
swab isn't causing any interference
and that you have repeatability from
from user to user
um so very easy you take the swap out
you swab your area again back and forth
put it in activate excuse you put the
swab in the tube activate
put it into the uh reader and then
you're gonna get your green
yellow or red reading tool number two
allergen testing so allergens are are
certainly a hot topic
we have um one allergen test that's
total allergen test called the flash
there are other swabs out there that
test these specific allergens
then we get the big eight and then in
canada they've got a couple more
um and we know the importance of of nut
allergies
i mean certainly we feel it when we fly
and they don't have penis on the plane
or if you're in your kids
um if you're in your kids cafeteria
they're not allowed to bring nuts or
so so allergies matter quite a bit and
so
you know we have again a total allergen
swab but these other allergies are
something you might be testing for
in a very similar way as you would be
testing for atp usually it's swabs
um and this is this is the offering that
we have
um so you still need to test the product
for allergen testing in the final
product but a lot of people are doing
environmental monitoring it's the same
idea
you're swabbing that four by four inch
sample you're activating shake it for
five seconds and then you're going to
read
except this one is a color a color
indication it's not an atp even though
it looks the same
and so we can really measure about 20
micrograms of the protein there isn't a
way to get down to
um three micrograms it's a secondary
process
that i didn't show here but again this
the swab
the swab sampling is very similar to atp
in but the next step is that it's a
colorimetric reaction
tool number three as our viable air
monitoring and compressed gas
testing um not everybody does
environmental or excuse me viable air
monitoring i highly recommend it
uh there's two ways to do it you can do
it settling plate which is putting a
plate out
and seeing what falls really only
captures anything above eight microns
even larger i would say
in a lot of cases whereas with an active
sampler you can say
i have x amount of contamination in
200 liters of air or 400 liters of air
and it gives you an actual number
that when you trend you'll be able to
see a little bit better it'll give you
something
that's more quantitative and those
captures uh particles down to about two
micron
so really any of your fine particles
that might be in there
active sampling this is our sieve
impacts this mas100 eco again there are
other samplers
out there but this is ours and this is
uses a 90 millimeter plate
and it has a little uh a little holes in
the top of this lid
and then this is our rcs that has
centrifugal impaction and those are
really the only two types of impactors
that are out there for viable air
sampling
um so active air sampling and again this
is active
uh you're pulling in air versus allowing
air to settle onto your plate
this is the mas eco how much are we
sampling well that's gonna depend
usually people are sampling enough to
get a countable count
the industry standard for the pharma
world um and even sometimes with the
nutraceuticals is a cubic meter
because then they can base everything
off of a cubic meter in a room that
might be
you know 30 cubic meters and they can
take one measurement and make
a trend over time but often in the food
industry
a cubic meter is too much and you just
end up with a plate filled that you
can't count
so really you should be sampling enough
so that you get a good count
and you can extrapolate and that's fine
um
because you're really just trying to get
an idea of how much contamination you
have
again trending so 200 liters 300 liters
is fine
how long again that's going to depend on
your hassle maybe you do it for two
minutes maybe you do
10 two minute samples that's just going
to depend on your risk plan
what do you want to know really what you
want to know is you want to know when
things spike
if you have a consistent 20 cfu per
sample
and all of a sudden you get 100 cfu
that's when you want to take action
you know that something is going wrong
you probably have some sort of harborage
um or some sort of contamination
occurred
that might have risk to your product but
what do you do with the data again
you're gonna trend it
you're gonna trend that data over time
to make sure that when you see that 100
cfu
you'll know that it's out of trend not
that it doesn't mean anything
and you say use your hassett plan make
sure that you're saying
i'm measuring where it matters the most
and i'm going to take action
when i'm out of spec
great so this is a picture of a hasset
plan i drew this picture myself it was
just a uh
it's sort of a 2d plan of a production
facility
and i put a little purple mark where i
want to do my active viable sample
i put a little red mark where i wanted
my passive viable sample
i might do personnel sampling after
they're done processing
my product i might do i'm just going to
do some atp
sampling in process as well as when i'm
done so
uh this is just a plan that you want to
have
when you're looking at your total
environmental monitoring
viable air sampling as well as personnel
you just want to have a plan that's nice
and easy to read
so centrifugal impaction this is our rcs
instrument and this uses a little strip
that is a little bit different than a 90
millimeter plate it takes
10 minutes for a cubic meter sample it's
one minute per 100 liters
so if you wanted to do a 200 liter
sample it's gonna do it in two minutes
excuse me it is very portable lasts long
this is example what the bugs would look
like on the strip
um so you just count those bugs and um
whatever you see and either we have
yeast and mold strips and tsa strips
it's cleanable and again i'm showing you
a centrifugal act we have one
there aren't many centrifugal impactors
on the market so this is an option for
you
um again there are other samplers that
do exist um of course we're a little
biased that ours are the best
uh so totally cleanable and let me go
back one
and uh this also adapts with our
compressed gas sampler so
this is a pretty common uh instrument in
the food and beverage industry for sure
and this is that picture that i was just
talking about this is that same
instrument
this instrument turns sideways attached
to this
compressed gas adapter so we'll talk a
little bit about these two instruments
again we're in the active air sampling
so sieve impaction
is where you have a head that has 300 or
400 holes
and you're drawing the air through and
impacting onto an auger plate
the nice thing about this is that all
auger plates fit um
you don't have to worry about uh where
your supplier is of course we have
plates
but all auger plates will fit again 10
minute sample same idea
it's one minute per 100 liters again
portable there's what you're
hopefully your plate doesn't look like
that but it's possible uh and that's
what your end result would be is you
would be able to just count all those um
organisms um excuse me colonies on the
plate
um so it also battery operated so for
compressed gas
where are the regulations well really it
just says that your compressed gas
shouldn't
introduce bugs into your product
sqf says yeah compressed gas shall be
clean and present no risk
to food safety and also monitored well
in order to monitor that means you have
to test
to make sure that your filters are
working believe it or not compressed gas
is pretty dirty
um there's a lot of water in compressed
gas systems that's why they put
dehumidifiers on them
there's oil so there's carbon content
and when you have carbon content and
water
that's definitely a breeding ground for
bugs so
compressed gas can be a major
contributor of contamination to your
product
so you want to make sure that it's clean
and we use filters to clean it
um but you still have to monitor so this
is that rcs with the compressed gas
adapter
again there are other methods for
measuring compressed gas
i don't personally recommend blowing gas
into a bag or onto a sponge those aren't
really all that accurate for measuring
your compressed gas
we do sell samplers and people do use
those other methods
it's just not going to give you that
much it's not going to be very
quantitative and not repeatable
so i recommend using a viable sampler
for compressed gas
uh and this um would attach directly to
your compressed gas line and you don't
have
you don't have any need to um bring a
pressure reducer
because the valve the the nozzle does
that itself and this could be used in
any compressed gas situation
in addition this head comes off and the
sample can be used for
viable sampling so this is a dual
purpose setup
which a lot of people really like
because they know they need to be
testing their compressed gas
but they can also use it for their
ambient viable monitoring
passive air sampling it doesn't get any
easier than this you take a plate
you put it out you leave it out about
four hours is the max
um most the data when you're talking
about a
deep fill like we are our plates are
naturally deep fill
they're 30 mils you're gonna get about
four hours before it starts to dry out
and anytime we have dry out we're not
sure that we can get the
kind of contamination recovery that we
want when we put it in the incubator
so max four hours i know people leave it
out for an hour or maybe
half hour so um passive sampling is
super easy settling plate
you leave it out and all it does is just
whatever falls onto it falls onto it
you can use tsa sda i would not use and
it's definitely not recommended to use
selective media meaning like a mcconkey
or a chapman or cetramide you're not
going to get the recovery that you're
looking for
because those are really designed for
subculturing not for direct
direct contamination detection so we
have different types
different varieties for for what you're
looking for for total bugs
and yeast and mold um also you can use
our mc media pad
what you do it's uh it's a pad that has
nutrients in it you leave it open
for three hours and then you add uh one
mil of sterile water
and then you cover it up and put it in
the incubator and read it the next day
and so that would be your final result
of an aerobic count of for air
sampling and then we're looking at
indicator organisms
so we're looking for bugs that indicate
that we might not have
um a clean environment something like
coliforms would be an example
so they indicate that there might be an
environment
that bugs that we don't want like
listeria salmonella or e coli
are growing um so it gives us an idea
too of the type of population that we
might have
with a similar idea with our our um
our uh atp testing we're verifying our
sanitation procedures
but we're verifying it a little bit more
geared towards
microbes we're looking to see what kind
of microbes are present
so it also makes sure that we if we
clean that it cleaned
again the clean the right way that the
we have process control steps that we're
making sure we don't want to allow
the ingress of these microbes and so
that's what this is going to be looking
for but again geared towards
microbes bacteria yeast and mold so we
might also be looking for coliforms
enterobacter aca we're trying to find to
make sure
that any of those harborage sites that
we know
can exist don't start to migrate to our
product
that's the most important thing and
that's what we're looking for with our
indicator organism testing again same
idea
you want to make sure that part of the
plan that you know you know
your process you know the you know are
you looking for chronobacter are you
looking for salmonella are you looking
for ecoliforms
you want to make sure that you
understand your product and what the
risk is to your product
again if you're if you're making baby
food and your chronobacter obviously is
a high priority organism
but if you're making like a dry product
a dry kind of
uh regular cereal product your
chronobacter might not be as important
to you
something along those lines this is just
an example of what might be
acceptance limits uh you know you might
have your target is less than 100 cfu
per gram
um a per sample maybe we'll call it a
swab
and then and then we will accept
anything less than 500.
so if i'm between 100 and 500 i know
that maybe something's going wrong maybe
i'm starting to have a build up that i
can't find
and that might be before your um post
heat treatment but before sanitizer
and then afterwards we say great we
sanitized it should be less than 10
cfu but we'll accept less than 100.
now if we're at 90 we realize that maybe
we didn't we weren't as effective as we
should be
again these are broad these are broad
ranges that give you some room
to make decisions it shouldn't just be
zero or one and it shouldn't be so tight
that you say i'm always cleaning or um
i i have i have organisms in my product
but it's really no risk to my product
you should make these decisions based
off of your product so this is just one
example of that
ah so uh em pathogen testing well some
people are gonna be looking
for actual organisms again most people
are looking for listeria you might be
looking for salmonella
you might be looking for e coli so um
if you had something in your zone one
like listeria obviously that's a direct
hazard to your product so you would know
so many many people
especially if the pro if the products
are a little bit wet or even
if it's cold storage they are they're
going to be looking for listeria
uh most people and if they find listeria
they're
they're going to um you know they might
idea to el mono
but it's going to be a cause for a
concern listeria again
some people might be looking for for
salmonella you might be looking for
chronobacter
it just depends on your product and it
depends on the risk of those pathogens
to your product
so for corrective actions you might stop
quarantine the product
and re-clean your you know you're going
to want to make sure that you retest
you're going to want to make sure that
whatever was there is no longer there
and if it is
then you know you've got some sort of
harborage and that bug is sort of living
in your environment
and that's not what you want so then you
want to say where did it come from
root cause analysis is important and
that's where if you have good data
throughout the facility
you might be able to determine that it
came from a raw material
or it was brought in with somebody and
those are two important things to know
um if you're doing a good environmental
monitoring program you might have
you might find out root cause is tough
everybody knows root cause is tough
because bugs are transient
and they tend to come and go and you
might say i have no idea where it came
from we tested everywhere
we couldn't find it again everybody
knows that but you still have to do
uh your root cause analysis so then you
just
in in that case if you do get a positive
pathogen you're going to repeat in
in zone one and adjacent zones until you
show absence in three samples
um and then you're going to resume your
manufacturing and close out that kappa
and that's why trend analysis is so
important to know
how um um how common that is happening
for you
so then in zone two three uh you
re-clean and then
repeat the test for a negative result
again it's not as critical in zone two
and three
it's still critical in zone two but not
like zone one
and then zone four you just want to make
sure um
you know that you're you're that you're
not
make you're you're not seeing that type
of pathogen in zone four because that
might be where it's
originating from uh so here's an example
something like in an rtu
or a ready-to-eat food segment um in
zone one i'm testing my product contact
site conveyors hoppers
and i'm looking for specific indicator
organisms and listeria and i'm doing
that weekly
post cleaning daily um and then it just
depends
how many would be dependent upon the
line that's just one example this is
just one very simple example
um and then adjacent to zone one i'm
gonna be looking for pathogens
weekly and a 10 to 15 sample and the
rest you can see
so that's the type of plan that you
should have again all based off a hassle
based off of your product and the risk
of those pathogens to your product
so what pathogen detection products do
we have available well
we've got everything as i said in the
beginning
everything from the from granulated
media to prepared media
mc media pad we have for rapid aerobic
yeast and mold
that takes a one mil sample um we got
transient plate for salmonella
and you know r2 rtu media we have
prepared
um not prepared excuse me we do have
prepared media prepared
um buffered peptone water we have
bottled media
media for latin broth and tubes we got
the sim plate that's a color
that looks for a total count and also
can look for
um other organisms
like campylobacter and then assurance
gds is for our pathogen detection
and that is for e coli salmonella
chronobacter
listeria and so we have lots of
different variety lots of different
products
for em indicators and pathogen detection
and i believe that is the end there are
some references and that's the end
of my presentation and i will
look to see if we have any questions
and thank you timothy for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now
just simply click on the ask a question
box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we already have a
few questions
coming in
first question is what is the main goal
of the environmental monitoring
yeah and one of the things about
environmental monitoring is
people you don't want to just do it to
do it you want to do it to find
information
because that information is what you're
going to act on you need to
you need to be able to act if you find
something and you don't know the
importance of that piece of information
then you won't know how to act so
environmental monitoring gives you a
plan
to know when to act and when you're
starting to see a trend
so that you don't end up having to throw
out food or throw out product
it gives you it's a good plan to reduce
the risk
of losing product in in the long term
thank you for that and i want to thank
our audience for these questions
coming in we do have time for a few so
please send those in
um while we're here what are some
environmental
monitoring mistakes or misunderstandings
that might occur
yeah so um a lot of times people think
that they
they get one result and they think oh
well this is a
this is a fail or i get one result and
this is terrible
and i you know what do we do here um
environmental monitoring is more about
trending it's more about knowing
what that what to do with that
information so a lot of people think
that
one piece of information informs my
entire process and it's not technically
true
really environmental monitoring is a
snapshot in time if you get a negative
today
you might get a positive tomorrow and
without trending without knowing
what uh that information i what i can do
with that information
people might either panic or they might
not act at all
so it's a snapshot every time we take a
sample it's just a snapshot
it doesn't mean that today my
environment was completely gone uh
um removed with with listeria that's not
technically what it means
it means that sample at that time did
not detect did not have listeria
thank you for that what audience member
wants to know can the flash allergen
also detect sulfite in the production
line
yeah let me give me one second
sure no it does not detect sulfite it is
detected
in that big eight for the united states
yeah it's sulfites not part of the
not part of that plant
thank you for that we have time for one
more question
how much air do food manufacturers need
to sample
for viable ear samples
yeah as i said uh it a lot of people i
hear
between two and four hundred the more
you can do
that gets a countable number it's going
to get you to an accurate
a higher accuracy so if you could sample
a cubic meter
and you end up with a countable range on
your plate then do a cubic meter
if you if you sample a cubic meter and
you have tntc on your plate
that's going to be too much you're going
to have to back it off to
uh 200. i see in the industry it's
mostly between two and five hundred
some cleaner environments will do more
but i would say it's between two and
five hundred
is the most common
timothy sierra thank you so much for
your presentation today
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we close today
yeah thank you uh you know environmental
monitoring seems like one of those
things
that uh is more like a why do we have to
do this there's a lot of samples
um there's a lot of negative results
there's a lot of
work that goes into environmental
monitoring but you know
uh the old saying a a pound of cure is
worth a a
an ounce a pound of cures worth an ounce
of prevention is
really how that how you have to think of
this when you're using your
tools to measure your environment you're
getting a heads up
and you're helping your company make
good decisions so that you don't have to
throw out product
so that you don't have to recall
products so that you don't end up on a
headline
because you have a listeria or an 0157
contamination
so environmental monitoring is a very
very useful
program to ensure that your facility is
under control
and that it's going to be beneficial to
your company in the long run
i want to thank you again so much for
your time today and for your important
research
and before we go i want to thank our
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time to answer
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
i'd also like to thank our sponsor
middleport sigma
for sponsoring this event and i want to
encourage the audience to check out
millscore sigma's booth and their
exhibit hall
go check it out this webcast can be
viewed on demand
through june of 2021. until next time
take care be safe have a great day
bye-bye everyone
thanks